share this tweet Western Maryland
literal Maga country with flags and
signs everywhere surrounded by
Republican districts to the west but
still broke for the Democrats after a
week of late counting elections today
are all about how the votes get cast and
not about how people actually feel take
a look at this beautiful little little
handlebar there in Maryland you see that
thing now look at this tiny little strip
you mean to tell me that this river
right here that cuts along here that as
soon as you cross that you immediately
go like I no longer like Donald Trump
now I'll vote Democrat I assure you
that's not the case you drive along this
and just like the districts of the North
End of the South it is Maga country with
Trump Flags Trump Signs Now how did this
District after redistricting which
became an R plus District go Democrat
it's the way the votes get cast mail-in
voting favoring ignorant people who
don't care they were projecting that
this would go Republican to Neil Parrott
and then at the last minute they started
counting new bouts new bouts new bouts
then slowly the Democrat flipped and as
soon as they did they called it that's
nothing is going to matter
moving forward because it's exemplified
right there so you know we can talk
about DeSantis doing everything right
but when it comes to the National level
if we have the Democrats in control of a
machine that it does it doesn't matter
if you know what's going on in vote
they're going to to find people who
don't know and don't care and they will
outnumber you again that's why I'm not
selling you on the federal government
here and I'm not selling you on the
grander project I'm saying certain
states can do it right and if you care
about any of these things then you have
to think about your life very seriously
and every time I tweet that out you know
you can move you know every well it's
not easy to move yeah it's not easy to
move whether you're single whether you
have a family your grandparents you got
kids whatever you have no money you're
rich everyone has their own
considerations but it is your life and
you have some capacity to do something
in your life and you got to decide what
you want to do because they set up State
elections uh so that you could vote
online and use like a blockchain to
confirm the votes could they do that
without the federal government saying no
you're not allowed I think that would be
worse could a state do it supposed the
state could do it I don't know
and you'd log into your account and it
would say thank you for voting and you
go I didn't vote though and they would
say it's on the blockchain you can't
change it but but I didn't vote I didn't
log in
yeah you should be able to confirm it
you got to be able to confirm your own
vote but I feel like voting on paper
giving it to Dominion or another
Corporation to tally the votes in secret
is like sticking your finger in a light
socket over and it's like oh I still
don't know if they cheated or they
didn't cheat paper ballots you need to
know you need to verify yeah even that
who's who's counting it it's
unverifiable I want a verified election
what do you mean it's unverified someone
takes it says thank you we're going to
count this honestly they go to someone
else and they're like yeah we counted
honestly that's right you get an
independent a Democrat or Republican and
whichever other parties like libertarian
and they all watch this so I don't want
four people to decide to verify for me I
want to verify my own vote I don't need
other people they're doing it for me
well in Florida you could verify your
vote that you voted online you get a
receipt I did at least and it's like oh
here's where you voted here's who you
voted like the count should be happening
by a computer in public I think we
should follow what Florida did I think
Florida made a lot of mistakes
especially in 2000 but I think they they
shaped up they know they have 99 of the
vote counted by by midnight that that's
impressive that's something that we
should strive to of course achieve as
well that's something that I think
should be universally put out I think it
was Style on this that doesn't matter
who votes but it's who counts no that
was Biden oh Biden no no I think it was
Stalin first and then Biden said it no I
know yeah but Biden did say it so and I
fully agree with that if other people
are counting your vote for you then
that's a problem you should beat yours
should be you know here's here's the
answer uh you know shows like this are
fantastic uh shows like yours and Luke's
but um we're preaching to the choir
I think culture is is everything so
almost almost all this I think basically
everything we've invested in at timcast
from you know all of you becoming
members at timcast.com has been cultural
it doesn't mean we're gonna be Disney
but we're certainly going to try and
have cultural influence making music
we're working on a video game we're
working on a show we're working on now
movies because you need to instill your
values in cultural things there needs to
be an industry where artists can Thrive
there needs to be an opportunity for
that guy who works for Disney to say you
know what I'm not making this woke movie
I'll go work for someone else right now
there isn't every company is doing the
esgbs ever so these people are like if I
speak up I'll lose my job okay well we
need to build that out the daily wire's
got an apparatus for it we're we're
slowly expanding that you just need to
keep doing it and as Society will will
grow great when men plant trees whose
shade they know they will never sit
beneath so maybe in 50 years maybe in
100 years I'll long be dead and there
will be some weird Tim cast company
that's got libertarian Freedom love and
liberal values or whatever and it's
supplants or displaces the weird woke
ESG stuff we Inspire young people to
build it they will come yeah something
like that like you may as well try to do
something on your own to defeat this
thing rather than saying oh my God if I
only had that politician there are going
to be a couple transformational ones
obviously I feel bad about DeSantis but
let's just make it let's let's uh hire a
bunch of young Tick-Tock influencers to
just talk about how how uncool is to
vote Democrat they won't vote Republican
they'll just say vote voting for
Democrats is so lame you're so lame I
can't believe you would do that did you
see the thing the other day where Biden
brought the tick-tockers into the Oval
Office and then they staged this idiotic
q a and one of the questions is should
Elon Musk be looked at by the federal
government and then he fumbled of course
through the answer but it's like yep
that's what I mean about everything's
fake it's all Bs we can see it we've
looked behind the curtain we've seen the
wizard we know he ain't the old powerful
full eyes but what do we do about well
one thing we can do is and and I
strongly encourage Rhonda Sanders to
begin immediately is to start building a
dyke system outside of Florida and then
draining the water to expand the
territory of Florida to accommodate more
and then you know I I've Breathing Room
breathing living in Miami I mean the
water is only three feet deep like 10
miles outside or like whatever it's I
think it's like 11 miles south of Miami
the water is like you could stand there
on the Rocks yeah that's crazy they have
stiltsville where they built those
buildings on stilts where it was like
international waters or whatever I've
been there it's crazy so you want to
literally like expand the land of
Florida yeah I don't think we need it
yet but we could start I think his next
thing like it is infrastructure projects
let's build more housing so that the the
competition that you were talking about
earlier about the house prices you know
here's here's a question if if Ron
DeSantis and this is totally
hypothetical If he if he brought in like
if he started actually bringing in Earth
ass yeah and dumping it alongside the
coast of Florida expanding would the
international waters go out with it or
how would that work that is a good
question I'm not a maritime lawyer yeah
um it's a very good question talk to my
Maritime lawyer he's on retainer yeah
it's like well you know the the water
extends like 11 miles to like
international waters but you know we
added a couple more miles of dirt well
most Florida's swamp anyway they have
pumps in Miami to get the water out so
and it gets flooded a lot so yep I mean
it's but we get flooded but you know
hurricane Ian hit basically a category
five as he described it a hundred year
biblical storm the I met a guy at the at
the um election night at the DeSantis
Amanda election night it was a
contractor in South Florida and he was
one of the guys working on the the
Sanibel Causeway and he said that this
thing would have taken two years in any
other state because of all of the red
tape two weeks let's let's talk about
Solutions in in cultural in the cult
cultural issues so before the show we
mentioned that Ian went on a tirade
screaming and slamming the table about
how Dave Rubin was a sellout and if he
ever got the chance to see him in person
he'd tell Dave exactly what he was like
razor blades that's why I came here too
um well its Segway is going to sit up
well so let me let me set this up it's
um we're dealing with censorship Elon
Musk buying Twitter and all of a sudden
the game has changed and a lot of this
bodes very very well for those who care
about freedom
we it seems like we're starting to make
tremendous gains in the culture wars but
with the daily wire success with Elon
Musk buying Twitter they can only they
can only hold on for so long with
universal mail-in voting with uh within
this there's Rumble which we use Rumble
infrastructure for timcast.com like the
whole website like literally the website
itself yeah the video player itself and
then we use parallel economy for our
memberships which is Dan bongino with I
believe rumble's invested in that as
well I think so so we want to build this
parallel economy you launched locals
yeah and then you sold to rumble yeah
and then we had a discussion about that
uh Ian said you were selling out and I
don't remember the entire the details
but this is what brings us to what we're
we're here now Dave's in the room and
Ian is just fuming and seeing red I'm
throwing the knife in the middle steam
coming off my shoulders and sweating uh
it transitions brilliant because we're
talking about culture we need to build
culture we need to make movies we need
to get people on our side vibrationally
they want to want people to walk into a
room and people will be like yes
whatever you say it's a little quality
but you need that to change the call to
change politics I think you need control
and culture but you also need control of
Technology because if you control the
technology no matter how much good
movies people are trying to put out
there you can just turn them off so that
kind of brings me to locals which you
were running at the time
um so you you started locals what my I
had two tiers of issues when you sold it
I think is my problem and the first one
was a bit more personal the other one's
more um I guess idealistic is that you
said come to locals I'll make sure you
never get banned and then sold the
company I was like well now he can't
make sure you never get banned because
he sold out I think I use the phrase
sold out to rumble whatever you saw the
company yeah
the other one is that I'm just concerned
with corporate conglomeration and
proprietary software because if Chris
gets killed you know Chris pavlovski if
something happens to him and then
someone else just owns everything all
the code so I think that we need to free
the software code so so I got yourself
that's a separate issue but yeah but but
I I the one issue that I that we brought
up that thought was really important was
they're doing the SPAC deal which means
they're they're going to go public well
they're through it now right you mean
back then when you were having the
discussion yeah so that means BlackRock
State Street and Vanguard will buy
chunks of this company and then it will
be absorbed into that machine so can we
let's just do one thing at a time here
so first off on the on the why so in
essence we merged the company's
basically merged I want I will tell you
100 uh honestly I sold all for stock
because I believe in it I did not take
any cash in the deal I still consult for
them that's the extent of what I do with
the company but I am telling you without
question there has never been a tech
company built in in any sense that we
know anything of that it is free speech
is baked into the ethos of this company
when I started locals our idea was you
know we wanted to basically personalize
a patreon for people so that you'd have
an app that would give you direct
contact with your audience and you could
build a business on your own so we sort
of viewed it as like we're building you
a house and what you do in your house is
up to you that's how we dealt with free
speech and we never had any problems
about it also because you have a paywall
which eliminates 99.9 percent of all bad
behavior so we had I felt we had a bunch
of good systems in place to to clean it
up in a really nice way and I think and
then it became very successful and we
got great investors in all of those
things I had a talk with uh we had a
couple offers to buy the company I had
to offer for massive cash life-changing
cash offer I had the offer in hand can
you say from home uh no but I had the
offer in hand good people bad people uh
good good actually
um and I went to Peter Thiel for advice
purely for advice and I said here's is
the offer what do you think I should do
with this thing and he said and I said
Peter I know this number that I'm
showing you is not a lot to you he's got
billions and millions of dollars but I
was like but it is life-changing for me
and my brother-in-law who's running
who's the CEO who's running the tech
change my sister's life change my
family's life right there and Peter said
look I'm looking at your numbers you
guys are doing some great things here he
said all you need is distribution if you
can figure out what your distribution
model is you have something amazing and
then I think it was literally like two
weeks later we got a call from Chris can
you guys meet me in Miami for lunch and
we were thinking okay we can partner up
with them somehow we'll figure out
something and Chris within I think the
water wasn't even poured I think the
woman was coming over with the water and
he was like let's figure out how to
merge and do this thing together I'm
telling you everyone on the board at
Rumble is in this thing for free speech
for every issue we've discussed here can
BlackRock and other companies figure out
ways to buy parts of course they can of
course they can I'm not going to tell
you that they can't Chris I don't know
what the numbers are so don't me on this
exactly Chris controls something like 74
percent of the company right now I think
that's it's something like that
um and he is an absolute All-Star on all
of these issues so if this type of deal
I don't mean this to you specifically if
this type of deal is not good enough for
someone like here you you know me right
like I started in this thing fighting
Tech censorship all of the nonsense that
New York Times was calling us all right
and all these things I started this
company for the right reasons we found
another company that's in it for the
right reasons at some point it's like
you got to do deals to grow and be
bigger and be and mature these things
and scale them and all of those things
um are we a perfectly decentralized
system we are not are we working on some
things including decentralized payments
and subscriptions we absolutely are
um that's like yeah the issue uh for one
all of that positive all of it that's
positive across the board and that's why
we use Rumble infrastructure for
everything plus so you can't be Google
alone let me just throw anything in like
for me like I would was running a
company that was a side job that I was
only losing money on right because I'm
putting time and resources into it and
but I didn't mind that like I actually
loved building it but like okay so now
Dave is somehow just through locals I'm
gonna be like I honestly think we can
beat Google I really believe that so
here's here's the trajectory I see
right now Rumble is operating off of
what I assume is like SPAC money or
investor cash
well this back is closed and now it's
fully public and traded on NASDAQ and
everything so yeah so they have they
have the money from the pipe and all
that yeah so so there's a lot of cash
there so the profit uh Revenue
generation for rumble is substantially
less than their cost their liabilities
exceed their their assets at this point
I would imagine
at a certain point there's going to be
an obligation to the shareholders to
generate Revenue
like Twitter what I see happening is
they eventually say how do we attract
advertisers that's how we have to make
money on this one or subscriptions
you're then going to run into one of two
problems advertisers are going to say we
will not advertise on this content
because it offends our delicate ESG
sensibilities you get no money from us
that's less of a problem with Rumble
because of rumble's founding whereas
Twitter was like hey our investors want
money we're going to go for it we're
going to appease the next issue is the
financial services which is why
um parallel economy is so important and
I think Rumble sees this well Dan who
started parallel economy is also a
founder of Rumble exactly these things
these things are connected like when I
tell you that the people involved in
these things when I have been to any
meeting with these people when I when we
were trying to figure out the merger I
never heard anyone say anything related
to speech in any way that would have
made any of it doesn't mean yeah Twitter
used to be the freeze between the Free
Speech party until their obligation to
their investors and then the advertiser
said oh yeah we'll advertise if you ban
that that guy with patreon they they
banned Robert Spencer because it was
reported that I think MasterCard ordered
them to do it yeah and the response from
the CEO of patreon was if we don't ban
this one guy ten thousand people lose
their livelihood and my response was let
the hundred million fans of those 10 000
people send an angry letter to
MasterCard when that happens yeah so
well you know I had him on my show and
he was lying to my face it was pretty
honest exactly so I think Jack Conte
yeah I think these are potential
pitfalls to going public getting
investor money eventually the bill comes
due and and rumble's gonna have an
obligation to public shareholders as to
how they generate revenue and what that
means so I would also say so I it's
totally legit I think another piece of
that that I think makes it a little bit
easier uh for somebody like you to
understand or not to understand but to
appreciate would be that the the
advertising game really is changing
right now like the cancel thing it's not
that it's gone but I think the days of
oh Ben Shapiro said something about
abortion now the soothe app is not gonna
right like go it just doesn't work
anymore we are getting to the other side
of it the Chappelle thing that we
started with is evidence that we're
getting to the other side of it there
also are all sorts of companies now
because of what the woke have done that
companies are now being built in across
all sorts of Industries
to build to make hats and do all the
culture stuff you're talking about
whatever it might be whatever product so
there's a whole new industry being built
that will support this sort of thing
that did not exist five years ago that's
just a reality but yes some of this
stuff has to be played out and yes when
you're a public company you have
different obligations than a purely
private company Elon has a lot of Elon
owns this thing now he's gonna have a
lot of problems when he realizes how
much money it's losing every day can I
just ask you one question because you
said locals have the ethos and the
belief system of freedom of speech what
made you believe that Rumble was going
to continue that because you made a
statement saying believe me these guys
are standing behind it what made you
believe that these guys were going to
follow those same ethos uh as you had
with locals so first off I assume like
all of you guys but especially you Tim
when when you've done what we do for
long enough like the idea that I would
cross my audience is so not not say
something they don't like but like do
something so fundamentally against what
I have put out there and what I believe
in it's I like I physically would not be
able to do it so I knew that I could I
couldn't I couldn't just sell it and be
like all right now they're going to
screw all you guys like and I wouldn't
do that it's it's against who I am but
but that's not the answer you're looking
for every meeting that we had with Chris
all he kept talking about was the free
and open Internet that was it that every
time we would get into more nitty-gritty
stuff he would punt some of that to The
Tech Guys because what he wanted to talk
about was saving the internet is the guy
who's from Toronto Canada dealing with
all I mean if you think about everything
that Canadians have dealt with in the
last two years covid and how could we
help the truckers like we were doing all
sorts of stuff uh how you know like we
every single person the board now I know
the board like these people are in it
for the right reasons it is not the
perfect force field
um for some of the reasons that you
mentioned but it's pretty damn good
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at Tim Cass dot com
for uncensored members only shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next time